here's a climate activist and author of
realize the earth Guardians guide to
building a movement that restores the
planet to tech Scott Martinez is back
with it
[Applause]
[Music]
how are you great to see you again I
didn't I know I think you're still our
youngest guest you were are young you've
checked this out okay maybe that's what
they told me anyways I think so yes we
don't we don't have that not a
children's show so and you were here
last time you're talking about the
lawsuit you and 21 other young people
500 so I think it's a great idea saying
you know the right the right to breathe
good air should be ours and federal
judge ruled in your favor it's going
forward now right so congratulations I
think one thing to note this incredibly
important is I think one of the biggest
problems we've made as a as a planet is
in the community is depending on our
politicians to do things for us when as
constituents we also have to be a part
of that process yeah especially as young
people when our futures our futures are
so directly connected to the way that we
address climate change that we have to
be at the forefront of the conversation
but we've certainly been left out so we
are demanding the federal government to
protect us from the adverse impacts of
climate change there was a motion to
dismiss filed by the federal government
and by the fossil fuel corporations
after two different judges federal
judges reviewed the case the motion to
dismiss they denied it so now we are
going to be going to trial on February
5th against the Trump administration
demanding that they uphold the GAR
constitutional rights as American
citizens
[Applause]
where do you see this going I mean what
is the end result that could happen from
this so best-case scenario is we win the
lawsuit and the top climb is top climate
scientist I'm a scientist to put
together a climate recovery plan there
is science-based evidence that will
shape the way that we address climate
change in this nation doing massive
reductions of greenhouse gases annually
until we get back to a safe level of co2
and greenhouse gases in the atmosphere
that is no longer threatening and
creating climate change so it's a big
dream and a big vision but I think they
too even have that conversation and the
fact that I lost you has gone this far
as incredible because it's not just
about the science it's the stories each
one of these young people is being
affected by climate change the youngest
plaintiff in this lawsuit lived in
Florida and he's gonna be affected by
the Hurricanes that are coming through
you know so for us it's more than
scientists it's more than science is
more than lots more than politics it's
our stories and it's our future
and you talk a lot about the fact that
it is not just cars and planes that
cause the pollution it's the way we eat
deaf it's a lot about the food I don't I
think I've talked about it myself many
times yeah I don't think people realize
cows do more damage than cars if you
want to just put it on a bumper sticker
definitely and people gotta recognize
that and so for something like for
example when trunk pulled out of the
Paris climate of course you know that is
something that everyday people don't
necessarily have a saying right you know
as far as a massive impact on the way
that we move forward in addressing
climate change but we eat three meals a
day and every single one of those is an
opportunity to make a choice for or
against our future for or against the
healthy climate you know so for people
out there understanding the impact that
eating meat and dairy has on our planet
is incredibly critical explain a little
why it's so bad for the planet so
industrialized agriculture is I felt
like a parent yes
it's just so much homework and check out
the garbage come on the book that I just
wrote we rise which is now going to
people all over the country has a really
really good section about food justice
so I definitely recommend you find the
book and reading about it there but
really I think looking at industrialized
agriculture and the impact that we have
as far as methane escaping from cows
they fart and they burp methane as well
as a massive amount of land and forests
it needs to be cleared right to grow soy
and corn that they feed to the cows the
amount of water that is wasted the
amount of transportation that goes
through it's a whole thing so so the
whole thing yeah all right so what did
you think of Trump wanting to pull out
of dhaka
mine you're a native you're partly I
mean yeah yeah Mexico my whole family is
Mexican right and for for me immigration
has been an incredibly important I mean
even more native than that you're partly
Aztec exactly they were here before any
of these white [ __ ] guys I
think it's it's looking at a demographic
of people in this in this nation and you
don't have a right to be here you know
when when it comes to that I think it's
it's besides the politics it's it's
about our stories and it's about the
youth you know it's about about the
young people here the people that came
to to this nation to seek a better life
you know and even for them it wasn't
even their choice in a lot of businesses
so I think that we have this
responsibility you see that after he
made the decision that were people were
furious all over the nation taken to the
streets taken to social media because we
realized that our president isn't gonna
stand up for the rights of these people
and in many cases when we look at the
action he's taken on climate change and
the action is taking towards minority
communities he's not standing up for the
people of this country and that's
something where we have to fight back in
our streets and on our courts you and I
I've got a smoke
[Music]
we gotta gotta smoke a bone with ken
bone after the show okay so you aren't
No
you're 17 right okay so you're not a
millennial no okay so you what no I I
have great hope for your generation
because the Millennials you know I mean
a lot of them come to my shows and I
love these people because you know
they're fighting against I think what is
the tide of their generation which is a
lot about trigger warnings and safe
spaces and microaggressions and usually
one generation backlashes against the
next so please tell me your generation
is gonna take a flamethrower to that
[ __ ] I don't know how they got so
fragile these Millennials but you got to
put some steel back we're gonna have to
be really resilient there you go